now von miller's girl's face was a
little tough the stuff you brought up
well
her body's really well hold on she's
pretty as [ __ ] oh yeah well her without
makeup is tough but go
and she has freckles yeah yeah me too
y'all know i mean y'all some haters dog
no hold on chins are here no we're not
hating it's just not my style that's all
i'm saying chin
you understand she's dating a football
player she don't give a [ __ ] about how
she looks right now
go to her single photos chin you with
the single phone
she's like do you think like cardi b is
bad or i think hard to be sad yeah
this is all her with javon miller i
don't like you could tell by that
you don't like what nothing what were
you gonna say i wasn't so into cardi b's
face in the beginning but she looks a
lot prettier you know it was tough
right i don't think it was done was it
the teeth it was a teeth i liked it
you like you like the teeth [ __ ] yeah
you heard what she said you have
straight teeth
yeah she said she said it was hard to
give head with those
straight teeth yeah go to go to the head
i like the flaws
that's enough yeah i mean go that green
one real quick and i'm gonna get off the
first one
come on chin come on
we're not on the same page on this
that's the whole that's what you think
that's a walking i think
she's gorgeous that's a pee right there
man that's a p
chin a p a p look at her thighs and you
oh yeah
she's that is a p that's good everyone
has a rotation she would take my money
in the strip club i'll tell you that
much bro
i remember i was in houston at 18 years
old and i'm how are you supposed to be
in there hit him
and uh we went to v live and all i was
just came back from the olympics we got
a little money my dad gave me a thousand
dollars now back then that's a lot
right a lot no matter what thousand okay
thousand dollars dog
do you know this girl name her her name
was uh delicious
right nothing i mean there's one in
every strip club okay well delicious but
i was she
she was like you want to go to a private
i'm like hell yeah she took me to a
private room and she did that dance
and i just threw all of your money but
about to i was like bro why are you
doing this you fell in love
oh so you don't need this she was like
yeah you're right i just i just like i
need a little bit more cash
and i can get out of here it's like here
just take it yeah come on standard story
you got hustle
yeah if i if i just had 500 i could
gas to get me to milwaukee got you come
on she just got you well she said she's
captain saboho she wanted to finish
school brenden of course yeah yeah
yeah what school was she going to she
didn't tell me that exactly well no but
no she said she said she was getting her
ba
in a communication yeah that's a lie
that's a lie
that's the easy one to say no it's not
you know how hard communication is how
hard you're pretty for you communicate
you got hustled and that's not a big
deal yeah i wanted her name was
delicious
but you had to go she was sober did you
have a good time i had a great time
exactly where was this
girl next girl she's like black girl
yeah i'm talking about what's better
than houston twenty
listen i know it was like we we was
talking for like six songs and you know
they charged by the song yeah yeah yeah
i was like
you thought you had a connection
what do you mean you know he's stupid
right
that's what that's that's their agenda
101 make sure the connection
he was eighteen
she got all thousands right every penny
yeah the whole thousand
and we i'll walk back and then
professional [ __ ] i got her number yeah
i got a number we take now whatever yeah
i got hanging out after that no
never you never did i was in the same
predicament that was when i didn't have
her number
when i had it that's basically what
you're saying yeah i didn't see her
afterwards
you didn't see her oh i texted her a
little bit i'm honest i'm the same i
think thank you
i thought love too yeah but at least i
know it's going on but i was 18. i
didn't know
i know she got you it happens did you
ever like have
experience with that no i mean the chick
brought me it was but this was a
whorehouse
can i say that yeah
were you in there for a hot second i was
in there for five minutes
and he said get out yeah cause cause
okay so it was so weird it was this
thing this is back home in arizona
so it outside it looked like these were
these were chappelle two on fourteen
days
no this one that was two thousand um six
oh oh yeah i was 19. oh six in a
whorehouse mm-hmm
okay cause i was moving to texas and my
buddy was like hey man
you know let's go out your last night
down let's go to the street club great
guy and i was like all right
[ __ ] yeah let's go to the strip club
yeah and we wrote we were driving around
for a long time trying to find one yeah
what was this spot it's a lot it was
like in an industrial area
you know it was like all weird and then
we go in and uh
there was rooms you know yeah and then
uh like strip like private rooms right
yeah it was rooms like it was like i was
like why [ __ ] the room you know
and they were like uh you go to the room
to the right you go to room to the left
oh you can
pick out the girl huh yeah a group of
girls came in and you were like
seven of them walked in like and they
literally like choose one of us
and i was like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah it took me so long my rush hour too
yeah
i thought it took you wait too long way
too long so i choose one you know
and white girl black girl uh there was
only white girls
arizona make sense in the horror
do you remember her name what the [ __ ]
no was it cinnamon or some [ __ ] like no
i can't remember okay but uh i just know
i was like
she was like okay so what do you want to
do i was like listen i'm only going to
stay here if my buddy's going to stay
here
it's just like okay let me i'll be right
back and then she goes she goes
she comes she leaves and comes back in
and goes oh your buddy's gonna stay and
i was like oh okay
well she probably just made that up
exactly because they never [ __ ] asked
him anything
no she went outside yeah yeah
so we got one we got a lot she should we
she was like i can't remember how much
she said they charged for the full
service
but i was like listen i only got like 50
bucks because i won't try to
well you know spend anything get your bj
i guess out there
no no yeah she just danced in front of
me for 50.
yeah for for uh five minutes but here's
the thing
i'm pulling out my money yeah right and
she snatches it
she just snatched my money all of it bro
and i was so terrified i was so young
that i just let her do it because 19.
yeah and then she she runs out
right all right and i'm sitting there
and i'm sitting here somebody's flopping
everywhere no no this is before she even
started
she because she takes my money and takes
it out there right
she comes back in dances from me five
minutes and then
then dude knocks on the door get out and
i was like okay so i'm sitting in the
lobby waiting on my homie
and i'm like man why the [ __ ] is he
taking so long what the [ __ ] is he doing
this school comes out
with his collar popped shoes off
he's been there right yeah i was like
bro you think you stumbled upon
us i was like what'd you do so he paid i
think it was like 450 bucks
that's expensive to jerk himself off in
front of the girl
in front of the girl but like what a
great deal for her well he got he was
like he goes out
so i negotiated for her to let me like
finger
at the same time so he paid for him for
that house cooch
yeah this is fingers
[ __ ] yeah it's still 450 and you're
jacking up
yeah it sounds like because he had to
put uh he said that he had to put a
towel over him
oh yeah he can't be just shoot yeah they
won't let him like have like that can't
be busted
she should have helped him out at least
she was just she was naked
that was all she heard so like his thing
was like he paid for
a service of he gets the jack off while
she just stands there [ __ ]
terrible deal that's all yeah they're
good looking yeah i used to no
they were busted but i'm telling you it
was in an industrial area it was like
all
you know your friend been there a bunch
of times
why was his shoes off in his collar i
don't know why because he was naked
oh he jacked off naked yeah yeah he's
close
he got hustled bro my homie my homie is
a radical [ __ ]
yeah i won't say his name come to the
show uh
no he didn't come to sean phoenix i
won't say his name but man he's ready to
tell you
oh are you a stripper i feel like you
get real tense in that strip club too no
i just love it back in the day though
when i was your tongue pissed
a little after the tongue creasing like
that like
you got down with strip club dude i used
to love it she does i used to love
cheetahs all right out here
no no no in las vegas oh yeah so
whenever we went to vegas we would go to
strip clubs and it was and then sapphire
too oh yeah oh yeah
did you do the rhino did you do uh
spearmint no you know there's like girls
and guys that's a spearmint rhino right
no i didn't know what do you mean
there's like the squirrels can go
somewhere about the same guys
there's like two different levels
did you guys ever hook up inside a strip
club no i just got home did you
i did like but not actual sex sex but
pretty much everything else we had on a
little private little
thing with curtains and my friends were
there with their strippers
in the boom boom room yeah so they were
i was all making out and
doing stuff how much did you pay for
this i don't remember my buddy paid for
it
really yeah have you been so you killed
that no never
no there hasn't been an occurrence where
i'd ever go
some chicks like it some girls do like
it i'm sure i'd have fun i just you
never had they'd be
all over you really yeah
they love when the guys come with girls
yeah dude from what i hear
no have you seen that uh rapper uh blue
face have you seen his instagram bro did
you see the hell
yes did you guys did you have you seen
it yeah
you seen this well oh my god hold tight
listen no no no i do your favorite
t-bird [ __ ] t
firebird hold on i'm going to see if
this bro instagram yeah
like they be hold on t5 they're nude
yeah
t firebird let me see it's always at his
house yes
it's at his house or whatever something
like that this is a young man with money
didn't he have like a reality show on
his only fans with him oh yeah the bad
girls club yeah
i i remember watching one only fans when
he's spilling milk on these
strippers yeah twerk into the milk hold
on i'm going to show you this
everyone was looking for this one
stripper i know oh the one that was like
yeah yeah i was saying t5 bird or
something like that
damn i didn't know you knew about his
instagram like bro
that shit's on world style oh yeah it's
always on yeah that [ __ ] was
hold on that [ __ ] was popping yeah
i was blown away at what he was like
showing on there yeah he's living life
man
i don't know this is the girl right here
that everyone was trying to find that
girl yes
yes everyone was trying to find oh
trying to find her bro she was going
crazy you didn't see what she was doing
oh she was going in let me try to she's
getting wild yes
it's like it's usually in his stories
yeah he'll get banned oh here it is
right here nobody firebird firebird pimp
firebird that's the girl firebird pimp
maybe she got like some stuff firebird
pimp that's all right here look
all right did she post anything yeah
that's her though okay
go to her story at least she looks crazy
yeah i don't see it there hold on wait
wait no it's time i don't know go up go
out
her uh story said uh that little circle
said bag season you know what that means
what's back season about to find out i
saw a lot of money go out work tonight
or
chill
how long this video lives in my head
real free
that's her there but yeah she's a
stripper she's a stripper
but she's wild i'm trying to wild what
do you want to look for
just keep going through her story let's
keep going through her story but look at
the bag season look at the back season
right there
oh to the far left you see it that makes
sense
here we go let's see what she doing this
is her with bags of money
okay wait wait that's bags what's she
doing with it hold on wait
all right look at that yeah damn girls
just be getting wild
they love bro they love you this
pandemic man
is that blue face story no all right we
got it right
she's all right looking yeah she was
going crazy you understand
that everyone was trying to find her
damn how'd you find her
that's her there let me see nah that's
not her i think i heard she on the
podcast
there's nobody else there it's a
pandemic it's a pandemic that's her
right there yeah here we go
is that blue face i don't know no
no that's the like it's a video whoa god
damn
what are they she's hitting her
scissoring is that what they call that
yeah i think so
are they pounding it though brendan yeah
i'm not into that
she's all right she looks a little
little hood wrap for me man
a little ratchet right yeah right yeah
well i don't know she's making bank
though she's that's what strippers i
mean what do you mean
well how do you see better looking
strippers than that but you i want them
nasty i don't i don't
it's cute women all day now if you just
gonna do all right you're right all
right i'm not mad at her yeah that's
true
she'd be hanging on some ugly dude some
hood dudes yeah
she hanging out some ugly dude man she's
stripping so hard her eyelash falling
off you see that
god damn she in la is she now late
this is this is a day ago by the way
all right that's enough okay not a
[ __ ] given with covet either
no this is 11 hours ago i'm telling you
if you see blue blue faces instagram
stories they're like
yeah insane yeah yeah he's living bro
living life
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song